He's the man who kills a king.
All of a chrome,
well,
the English puritan sounds,
military dictator is today most famous for signing the death warrants that led
to Charles the first bloody execution in 1649 over a hundred years before the
American and French revolutions shook the globe.
This small time British farmer from the British sticks proved with steel,
the divine right of kings was not so holy after all.
What possessed a guy who worked in agriculture to drop his tools one day and go
and commit regicide?
The story is even more fascinating than you probably think from his humble
backgrounds.
Cranwell would rise to become a leading puritan and tireless advocate of
religious freedom even as you committed war crimes on the battlefields of
islands and pursued personal empowerment with a terrifying zeal.
And I'd also some I go to others.
This is the true story of the man who spearheaded England's civil war.
Like many great amount of history,
I'll have a crumb.
Well was born into surprisingly modest circumstances,
well modest for the 90 classes of Britain who in the dying days of the 16th
century were the only ones who really mattered.
The second of 10 children.
Young Oliver was the product of a Protestant family that has done well out of
the reformation seven decades earlier,
rising from brewers do owners of a smaller state.
He could trace a family link back to Henry.
The eighth adviser,
Thomas Cromwellian and his nearby grandfather frequently entertains James the
first rail hunting party.
Young old liver may not have been rich,
but he was certainly well connected.
He was also growing up in the shadow of Britain's most notorious terrorist
attack in 1605 vengeful Catholics had gunpowder beneath the House of Lords
intending to blow up the king.
The pilot's discovery fired off a wave of anti-catholic fervor across England.
Something this may well have helps form young Oliver's strict Protestant outlook
terrorism side,
though the reign of James the first was mostly stable and all of the lives,
a mostly stable life.
You attended school,
spent a year at Cambridge University.
They need to be forced to return to the family's east Anglia estate.
After his father died in 1620 he married Elizabeth [inaudible] and does that
really should have been that.
However,
in 1625 something happens that would act as a catalyst for all the bloodshed
there was about to follow.
On March the 27th James the first died,
his son Charles the first inherited the throne.
It was the start of a long march towards catastrophe.
Charles the first was by most accounts they're shy and draw the sweet fellow in
private in public.
He was everything that growing pirouettes and movements in England feared his
wife was a catholic.
He supported a form of Anglicanism that appear dangerously close to Catholicism.
Oh.
And he was super keen on raising taxes to send his friend,
Lord Bucking and gala van zing off to fight foreign wars that England did not a
chance of winning.
When the new king convened his first Parliament in 1625 it became known as the
useless parliaments because its members refuse to vote through those new taxes
that Charles wanted.
And I Charles dissolve the parliaments after just 12 days.
One yet later he tried again only for the mps do also refuse to raise taxes that
would be wasted on Buckingham's boneheaded back narrowing.
So once again,
Charles dissolved parliament and by the way,
get ready to hear that sentence a lot.
Well,
London was indulging in high politics back in east Anglia.
I'll ever chrome.
Well,
it was in the grip of eight severe spiritual illness,
plagued for years,
like serious depression.
He finally slipped into a funk one night that became a fever and that nearly
became death when he finally recovered.
He was a changed man.
Cromwells would later describe as experiences emerging from darkness into light,
the light of puritanism.
From then on,
he would be a staunch defender of the puritan faith.
The road to Damascus style conversion.
Me explain what happened next.
In 1628 Charles the first decided once again to try raising taxes and cold.
Yes,
another parliaments.
This time Cranwell decided to join using those connections that we talked about
earlier.
He managed to literally get himself a front row seats to the most explosive
parliaments in decades.
By 1628 Charles had resulted to extracting money from his subjects of sorta
points known as forced loans.
They were as unpopular as daylight.
Robbery tends to be,
and it became even more so when bucking him,
use the money and not just for disastrous adventures in Spain,
but also to launch an identically disastrous war with France that Charles had
resulted due locking up mps who refuse to pay,
only added fuel to the dumps.
Defy.
That was now the new parliament.
As a young chrome,
well looked on,
Charles refused to accept the new parliament succession of the rights to refuse
unwarranted taxation.
Parliament blamed Buckingham for influencing the king.
I mean,
if a young army officer to then assassinate Nord boneheads Jarls blamed nps for
the death of his friends and you guessed it,
he does all phenomenons.
He did this in something of a fit of Pique and that peak,
by the way,
lost it for 11 years.
No parliament would sit from March of 1629 to April of 1640 this barrier became
known as the years of personal rule for chrome.
Well,
personal rule was tough.
Sean of his parliamentary standing,
he wound up losing contact with his old network,
selling his property and taking on a small farm in Cambridgeshire to survive.
By 1636 crumb was a broke unimportant.
Nobody with zero prospects even considered emigrating to America and joining in
with a pilgrims.
Thankfully the 16 fatties closed with do bits of good luck for Cranwell first in
1636 is fabulously wealthy.
Childless uncle died and left Oliver everything.
Seconds in 1639 Charles the fest at something Spec stupid.
He tried to force his religious beliefs on Scotland and downtime.
Scotland had been in union with England and Wales for less than 40 years.
Scott's still worshiped presbytarian style with none of the fancy stuff.
So beloved of Charles.
When Charles tried to ram his religious reforms through the Scots,
they went nuts,
known as the bishops was the following battle,
saw Scotland invade and occupying northern England.
Charles sued for peace and the Scott said essentially,
sure on two conditions.
One,
no more of this fancy religious Bollix and to pay us all of our war expenses.
So you're completely broke with an occupying army in the nation's north.
Charles was forced to grit his teeth and summon another parliaments.
This attempt would go even worse than all of his others.
The parliaments of 1640 got off to a farcical stars known as the short
parliament.
This time,
it lasted only three weeks before.
Oh yes.
Charles dissolved parliament,
but there was still broke.
So he called for you.
I said another parliament just six months later.
And finally we reached the end of our run of Charles dissolving things because
the second vitamins of 1640 isn't known physically as the long parliament.
Although the long parliament wasn't a straight revival of the 1628 parliament,
it did feature some familiar faces.
Among them was Oliver Cromwell.
Now with influential puritan with new connections,
Crum well became MP for Cambridge during the 11 years of personal rule,
had lost his shyness in the first week of the long parliaments.
He made an impassioned speech attacking the king's imprisonments of freeborn
John.
In the seconds he launched a ferocious broadside at Charles is his attempts to
force his brand of Christianity upon his people.
While the speeches were hardly Mencken or church or they were passionate enough,
that crumb well began to get noticed while an ax putting some of Charles's taxes
on a legal footing kept to the king's somewhat happy.
Parliaments also passed bills accusing his advisors of treason and making it
illegal for Charles to dissolve parliaments without their consent.
Oh,
and they also attacked his Catholic wife because that's just how things are.
How they went down in 17th century person.
By 1641 things had completely deteriorated as if a war had erupted in Ireland's
a royalist coup had been crushed in Scotland.
Then parliament wins and presented Charles with something called the grands.
Remonstrance.
This was basically a top 10 list with the title of the reasons we hate you.
You stupid tyrants,
never imagine to take criticism.
Well,
Charles became convinced that this was all a puritan plot against him.
On January the fourth 1642 Charles led a group of soldiers into the House of
Commons to arrest five prominent mps.
I mean,
it's unprecedented in English history,
but the Mvs,
they weren't there that had been tipped off and flat embarrassed,
convinced the world was against him.
Charles left for London on January the 10th when he arrived in his traditional
haven of Oxford.
He began raising an army.
In March,
parliament voted to raise their own.
By now,
everyone met a fairly good idea of where this was heading.
In August,
1642 the first English civil war finally began pitching royalist forces against
parliaments army.
It would ultimately lead to some 200,000 deaths.
Unfortunately for most,
but not all for Oliver Cromwell.
This would be the moment when he stepped out of the shadows into the blinding
light of history from the get go chrome.
Well,
it was at the heart of the war,
even though he was just a farmer with no fighting experience.
One of the very first engagements of the conflicts came when he successfully
garrison Cambridge against a royalist attack,
but it would be at the battle of edge hill in October where chrome well really
became a soldier.
The battle was a stalemate,
but chrome well was able to witness firsthand the effectiveness of the
royalists.
Horse mounted troops convinced the parliamentarians needed cavalry to win the
war.
He had his back to east Anglia to raise a mounted army.
It's almost impossible to overstate how effective Cromwells horseman would
become.
By mid 1643 they'd security Stankonia for parliaments in 1644 of the wipes the
floor with Charles,
his own amount of troops at the battle of mustard more chrome well was such a
natural leader of men that he was soon promoted to leftenant general and given
the nickname iron sight has men work professional disciplines and loyal
qualities sorely lacking in the rest of the parliamentary Ami.
In fact,
it was Cromwells obvious military skill that stops him from exiting the story.
At this point,
fed up with XRS to Kratz leading their army.
Parliament passed a motion in 1645 to kick every MP and Lord out of the military
as MP Crockwell should have been among the parliament,
passed a second law allowing him to continue serving on to a new leader,
Thomas Fairfax.
They knew that winning the war rested on Cromwells cavalry.
In 1645 Cromwells horseman played the decisive role at the battle of Nazeem.
Here they effectively wipes out the royalist army.
Charles held firm for another year,
but in 1646 Cromwells took his stronghold of Oxford.
Charles floods into the night disguised as a seven.
He traveled north and threw himself on the mercy of his old enemies.
The Scots.
That's surprising me.
This got straight at him doing glands and with that,
the first English civil war was over
remarkably for a regicide or dictates that at well responded to Charles's
capture by trying to force parliament to cut a deal with him.
Cromwells sincerely believed that the only way forward was to restore Charles
the first of the throne,
only with a new constitution in place to stop him running around and raising
taxes and dissolving parliaments.
The hero of the parliamentary cause even droid a rebellion against parliament
that year using his influence to four sounds,
11 presbytarian nps that he considered anti Yami.
If Charles the first had been just at a little bit less of a start on ass,
it would have all ended right at sadly being an ass was Charles was old about
despite losing the war,
he refused to accept any deal with parliaments.
Instead he got a secret deal with the Scots to make the whole of Britain
presbytarian if they're just invade and restore him to the throne and the Scots.
They agreed and so we come to the embarrassments.
That is the second English civil war.
Embarrassing because of it's farcical,
lack of coordination.
Let's stop risings paralyzed Wales and southern England in 1648 but the Scott's
didn't invade until Cromwells well and Fairfax's.
He subdued them in August.
Well,
road north met the Scottish Armenians.
Annihilated adds so much for that.
However that what two important outcomes from this second dustup.
The first was that the army forcibly purged parliament of Mbas who didn't
support Cromwellian Fairfax.
This severely reduced lung parliaments became known as the rump.
The second was that Charles,
his role in the Scottish invasion was inevitably discovered.
We've Cromwells blessing the rump drags.
Charles,
before Isans held a mock trial,
he was sentenced to death,
the 59 MBS,
including chrome,
well dead,
to put their names on the execution order.
On January the 30th 1649 Charles was publicly executed in London.
His head lopped off and hell's a loft for the crowds to see unpopular as he
wants to.
It's thought Omnia a hundred I'll say men in the whole of England wanted to see
him debt.
It's just a shame for Charles that one of those men happened to be all if a
Commonweal.
Yup.
Powerful as chrome.
Well was at this stage.
He didn't just transition straight to Ruder of Britain.
After Charles died,
it was the rump that now held supremacy and chrome well was pretty fine with
that.
They supported his army and besides history,
it's still had one major task for him in 1650 chrome.
Well,
it was sent to end the Irish war.
The Irish rebellion had been bubbling away in the background the entire time.
England was in chaos.
Now that the chaos was seeming the Ivr,
it was,
I mean natural that England would want its way,
would province back,
sadly to achieve the same chrome.
Well did some Trudy terrible things.
Cromwell's massacre is a droid and Wexford are still remembered for that
cruelty.
Both involved Cromwells besieging a town then offering new quarter two soldiers
or civilians.
Thousands and thousands died.
While some historians have suggested the scan of suffering was exaggerated.
Those little arguments,
both sieges comes to shooters,
atrocities still they did ends the Irish rebellion and chrome,
well returned to England in 1650 just in time to [inaudible] himself in the mess
of the third English civil war that,
yeah,
Charles,
his son Charles,
the second reopens his father's packs with a Scotsman who was proclaimed king of
Scotland.
Parliament demanded that Scott's be crushed,
but Thomas Fairfax refused to attack first.
So chrome well was made commander in chief and he was sending north in September
of 1651 he finally defeated the Scots of the battle of Wooster.
And this marks the end of the civil wars in Britain.
So what does a general,
he was one,
three civil wars and crushed her rebellion.
Do in peacetime?
Well,
luckily for Cromwells,
different sort of war was now brewing in Westminster.
The rump was getting mad with power through 1652 to 1653 at Pasta.
No useful.
That just Alation except to make itself immortal.
The rump has come into being as a stop gap,
a temporary measure until the wars were over into new elections,
could be called [inaudible].
Now they were voting to end elections permanently.
By April,
1653 chrome well had had enough in a delicious historic irony.
He sent troops into Westminster echoing Charles,
his own breach of parliament 11 years earlier.
A gunpoint.
He told the rump,
you have sat too long for any good you have been doing lately and the name of
God go.
There are gone.
Grunwell gave parliament one last shot in July,
1653 he convened a new national assembly,
popularly known as bad burns parliaments.
It's 144 members were hands picks for vest saintliness grunwell expected them to
rule his new puritan Britain as enlightened men and instead they voted to
dissolve themselves and handle all the power over to Oliver Cromwell.
Okay.
Chrome whale is often portrayed as a power hungry tyrants,
but all evidence indicates that he really did try and refuse absolute power.
In the end,
the peak of the teenagers,
the 15th century tonight sort of Lord protector was revived for his reign under
the new constitution was drawn up known as the instrument of government.
It's spit power between Cromwells they 15 men council of state and a new
parliaments of 400 elected representatives from England,
Scotland,
Wales and Ireland.
This was actually kind of progressive.
Never before had Scotland or Ireland had been guaranteed their own MBA's and
seats.
So the eds,
they'd got 30 each,
not that this miles progressive.
Ben Stopped to the parliamentary wheels from soon falling off though elections
to the first protector at parliament were held Fredy resulting in a swath of
presbytarian and Siyani free thinking and Roya stem piece being returns.
Oh,
and also some of the members from the rub came back.
Not exactly the biggest Cromwell.
Well,
fans chroma has hope that the new parliament would pass necessary legislation to
move England's off a war footing,
but instead they set about reducing Cromwells powers when they tried to reduce
the Ami t allows it.
In January,
1655 Cromwells dissolve parliament.
The new dissolution came as word was leaking out about Cromwells secret 1654
deal with Catholic France to ally against Spain.
Once again,
English taxes were being used to finance boneheaded adventuring volume over
bearing Monique,
you dissolve parliaments like it was going out of fashion.
The irony was lost out on absolutely no one and many of Cromwell's allies began
to turn against him still.
He wasn't broadly unpopular just yet.
There's a guy called Penn radic discovered in March of 1655 sure that Cromwells
rule was about to collapse.
Penn Roddick organized a royalist uprising intended to put Charles the second on
the throne.
He gathered man,
man,
set off across England's rallying locals stores cause only for locals to shut
their doors to him.
Panic is men simply ran for their lives.
Penn radix dismal uprising.
It was crushed before I dealt with again.
Penn Roderick's uprising may have been amateur hour,
but it gave chromeo the excuse he needed to scrap the new constitution and set
up a military dictatorship,
England and Wales,
but split into 12 districts each under the control of a desk spotting major
general,
hugely unpopular.
The system lasted barely a year before Cranwell was forced to scrap it and
revive parliaments in September of 1656 only the seconds protector at parliament
wasn't freely elected.
Purged of Cromwells enemies stuffed with toadies finally voted in February of
1657 to make Cranwell king.
Oh yes.
He was really made king.
The very thing that chrome well had fought so hard to read,
written off to be absolutely fair.
They Britain's entire system of government relied on a king or queens,
give Roya sends ins,
wave things through.
So having one was something of an urgent legal matter.
It does not mean it's chrome world was on an idea king and all,
but name.
He was totally referred to as his highness.
He lived in Charles the first solid palace and was handing out nights do all of
his friends.
So yeah,
that's what a king does.
Andrian the 26 1657 protector at Britain decided to make it official.
Cromwell was crowns in our lavish ceremony.
That was almost in every respect a coronation.
The only difference was that he kept to the Lord protector title instead of
becoming King.
If you're struggling to see the difference.
Yeah.
Well,
so in many of Cromwells old comrades,
in fact,
they were struggling to see the difference between the protector is and the is
of Charles,
his personal rule.
King Oliver was levying taxes.
Do you fight pointless wars and dissolving parliaments at the drop of a crown?
Oh yes.
And we're not done yet because he totally did it again.
In February,
1658 the second protector at parliament voted to grow a backbone and readmit MPs
excluded by Cromwells man.
So that was it for the second protector parliaments,
the last few months of Cromwells life saw him withdraw from public affairs.
His daughter Elizabeth died of cancer in early 1658 and it seems something in
chrome.
Well,
some vital spark just vanished.
He stopped receiving people or even really ruling.
Perhaps he realized what he'd become and was disgusted by it.
Perhaps not.
On September the third 1658 the man who was almost king Oliver passed away that
night.
A terrific storm.
Racketing vins houses were torn apart and scattered by the winds.
Ships sank beneath the rolling waves.
It was said that the storm was Satan come to take theater door to protect us
soul.
Although the protector,
it would survive another year under Cromwells son Richard did effectively died
with chrome.
Well,
Richard would last less than a year before being deposed and replaced with the
revived rump.
The Rambaud in Zen barely reconvened before an army general known as George
Monka marched on London and ordered the rump to readmit it's excluded members.
Long Parliament was then revived,
just long enough vote for it's own solution.
Then you convention parliament that followed in 1660 immediately voted to
restore Charles the second to the throne,
so the English interregnum ends it.
Charles the second was on the throne with the only new limitations on his powers
being those proposed by the long parliaments back in 1640 everything that
happens in the intervening two decades,
the three English civil wars,
the Irish rebellion,
the protectors,
they all became effectively pointless.
Cranwell had raised an army and killed a king,
but within two years of his death,
his achievements that all turned to dust.
On January the 30th 1661 Cromwells body was disinterred 12 years to the day of
Charles,
the first sex education alongside the corpses of two other prominent
parliamentarians.
It was symbolically hung at Tibor and gallows before being beheaded.
As late as 1685 you could still see the former lord protectors head on a spike
outside Westminster.
It was all the bloodshed for nothing without a doubt.
Cromwells did some terrible things during his long career.
He committed atrocities in Ireland and this personal ambition turned what could
have been the world's first liberal revolution into it,
like Ganache,
flop.
It would fall to American and French revolutionaries over a century later to
complete what the English had started.
But Cranwell was also a truly great general,
a leader of men who could stand shoulder to shoulder with Washington or bolivar
without Cromwells.
You have no parliamentarian victory in the English civil wars without
parliaments victory.
None of the ideas that would lead to influence the founding fathers gain any
traction from,
well,
he was an ogre,
death spot fool,
and a failure.
He was also the man who kills a tyrant king.
And in doing so,
I should in our modern world.
So I really hope you found the video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Do not forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like this twice a week.
So subscribe.
So you get those in your inbox and click that bell notification thing because
subscribe doesn't always tell you,
oh,
you put out these videos.
If you do want to see them do click,
that's like I say,
like it subscribed.
Why not?
And I'll see you next time.